[Music]
[Applause]
it's kenny pickett the pit quarterback
and a heisman finalist who joins us on
the program kenny good morning official
height and weight is what
official height and weight six three
three eighths two twenty two all right
so almost six four
almost six four i like that you didn't
round up okay you're you're telling the
truth i like that it's so some good
that's right good qualities are coming
yeah you got your degree
yes sir in marketing okay what are you
going to do with that
uh we'll find out hopefully hopefully
play football for a little bit and
figure that one out
uh how would you market yourself
how would i work on myself for for the
nfl yeah
um i mean i would just say uh
i mean the tape the tape is your best
tool in
in in football so you know no matter
what i say or anybody else says
you know you just roll the tape you find
all the answers there
when did you realize that you could play
at a high level that you could be an nfl
quarterback
i believe this since i was young and i
always just worked so hard towards it
and um
you know i just i i don't know just
through all the ups and downs i always
kept that belief i think that's kind of
what kept me going in the right
direction and staying staying focused
and always working hard and getting
better every day then it kind of just
came to fruition for me you grew up in
jersey favorite quarterback growing up
donovan mcnabb i was a big eagles fan oh
did you meet him
i met him once that was kind of like a
fan favorite i got some pictures uh i
was like six or seven years old so it
was bad it was back in the day
do you remember uh what it was like that
feeling
i do i do want to i mean i was a huge i
used to go to the games with my dad all
the time i took an hour and a half drive
from my house and we grew up big eagles
fans um that one famous game against the
green bay and brett favre and uh i was
at that game back i think like 2005
maybe
um so i yeah it's way back
eagles eagles got three first-round
picks there kenny
they do they do
we'll see what happens
okay
would you want to follow dan marino's
footsteps and i know you went to pitt
but mourinho of course played for the
dolphins steelers famously passed on him
so you could play pittsburgh or you
could play for the eagles if i gave you
those two choices what would you take
oh those are great choices i would take
whoever has the higher pick whoever has
the first option
okay all right i'll take i'll take
anywhere um you know just the dream of
playing in the nfl is you know you know
since i was a kid since i picked up a
football so i i would love anywhere
uh as far as the uh the picket slide
where you didn't give yourself up and
you kept running
how long had you thought about that move
against wake forest
i i never thought about doing it ever um
it was just kind of an instinct thing uh
i couldn't i i got to the sideline all
the quarterbacks were asking like what
was i thinking how did i what was i
planning on doing
i had no idea i just kind of i blinked
and the next thing i knew i ended up in
the end zone so
i just kind of felt as a player you just
kind of feel things i felt them pull up
before i even was going to start to
slide i think that's the only way i
could have had that idea to do that in
that moment and how fast i was going um
but you know where it worked out for us
do you think they're going to change the
rule
oh i'm sure i mean
people are saying i cheated i think
that's a little you know ridiculous
there's no rule for it um you know
there's there's guys that fake running
out of bounds and all that stuff and you
know i've never done that this was just
kind of like
i couldn't even tell you what i was
thinking i just went out there and did
it
but i guarantee with how much publicity
it's getting i'm sure there will be a
rule next year well how surprised are
you at that publicity
i was pretty surprised i thought in the
game i was just like oh i mean i made a
play i didn't think it was going to be a
big deal um
until obviously after the game and and
days after the game it was still being
talked about
um so yeah i mean it is what it is i
mean we won by
20-something points so i don't think
that was a deciding factor in the game
but um definitely a big play to start
the game i think you can only do it once
though kenny
yeah no i couldn't do it again if i
tried bro i could you know i've never
practiced it i've never
i don't know how i don't even know how i
came up with it on the fly i just did it
just being a player so yeah
are you playing in the peach bowl
well with you know recent news and and
out of you know
our team with coach whipple and
everybody you know that's something i
actually just got home yesterday and i
didn't get a chance to talk about it
with my parents i'm just kind of
enjoying the season and getting a chance
to see some family who haven't been
around in in a long time so um but
definitely i'll be talking about that
with my family here soon so you're
undecided
i'd say undecided right now yes what
happened with coach whipple uh stepping
down your offensive coordinator
yeah i mean that's that's personal with
with his decision and the information he
gave me so i'll keep that tight but um
it happens things happen and um you know
he has his reasons and um you know i
can't thank him enough for all the
things that we were able to accomplish
together in three years and seeing how
much we grew in the fir you know looking
at the first two years to last year
just a lot of hard work and uh you know
very grateful for uh coach whip
yeah and you know i go back six years
ago with christian mccaffrey and he sat
out a bowl game and everybody was up in
arms and then leonard fournette sat out
didn't play in a bowl game uh kevon
thibodeaux at oregon is probably not
going to play in a bowl game
you we haven't seen quarterbacks i don't
think do it but i understand
like what is the risk and the reward for
you playing in the peach bowl like what
do you think you could gain by playing
in the peach bowl
i mean i'll be honest with someone i
haven't you know sat down and discussed
with my family it's been kind of a crazy
past couple days
um you know getting the johnny united
news and the heisman news and it's just
been kind of a a whirlwind of two days
and driving back to new jersey so um i
think you know these next couple of days
i'll be able to sit down and really
figure that out who's coming to new york
for the heisman ceremony
i'm 45 minutes like an hour south of the
city so um i plan on having my my
girlfriend my mom dad my sister
definitely will be there and i think
there's going to be like you know
probably 100 people at a spot with 20
minutes from it that we'll go meet up
after and uh get a chance to you know
celebrate and see a lot of friends and
family so uh it'll be a special day for
sure who would you vote for the heisman
who would i vote for i'd vote for myself
um
you know just all all the things that
you know i've done this season that
hasn't been done in school history and
acc history
um
you know i just feel like i'm the best
player in the country
good
got to have confidence in yourself
i think bryce is going to win the
heisman but you know it's a great honor
to be able to you know represent your
school and and it's one of those moments
that's that's going to be history when
you're there you know even if you're in
the audience congrats on the great year
a great career i should say and good
luck with that decision i know it'll be
difficult in deciding if you're going to
play or not and we'll be following thank
you kenny
absolutely thanks so much have a good
day
that's kenny pickett uh he's going to be
one of the final four
the finalists there going to new york
city he'd vote for himself do i think
he's going to play in the peach bowl i
don't